it's been almost a year since I got my
Apple watch Ultra and now that you can
buy a used one for under five hundred
dollars I want to share it with you guys
seven positive things that I did not
expect along with five negatives or
downsides about the Apple watch I'll try
and let you guys know if you should buy
one if you are still on the fence now
the first thing that I didn't expect is
that I would wear it all the time when I
first got this thing I thought it looked
a bit too sporty and it wouldn't work
for more formal events so I kept my old
gold stainless Apple watch but after
swapping out the band for this 35
titanium band it looks way better no
matter what I am wearing and I literally
stopped wearing that gold one number two
is the durability and it is insane now
when Apple said that this thing is tough
they actually meant it I've been doing a
ton of construction
for about the last half a year and I've
been wearing it pretty much all the time
I've been hitting it against things I've
actually dropped it a few times on the
concrete as well and I literally have
not a single scratch on this thing there
might be one or two little Nicks that
aren't even noticeable but this thing
pretty much looks like new the screen is
also pristine not a single scratch and
that is crazy for a year of hard use
other Apple watches even the better
stainless steel ones do not look this
good after a year number three is
waterproofing now it's obvious it's a
watch it should be waterproof but I use
mine all the time in water whenever
we're out swimming I keep it on it's
rated for up to 100 meters or 330 feet
so that is crazy so you should be fine
using it but I've even swam with it in
salt water which people say you
shouldn't do you but it has had no
issues and I love using this as a tool
to control music so I'll have music on
um either either in the boat or on the
beach and then I can just switch songs
adjust it in the connectivity even at
far distances is excellent so that has
been really nice this last year now
going with that to number four that is
the battery life this thing lasts for
days and light usage up to three days
for me some people have actually
mentioned four and then for heavier
usage two full days and that is actually
the biggest reason why I actually got
this thing now I recently made a video
about battery life issues with my iPhone
14 pro but since I always have this
thing on me if or when my iPhone dies I
don't really have to worry about it much
because I could still get notifications
texts and calls on my watch and even
playing music sending Bluetooth out it
works great now speaking of that that
brings me to number five which I think
most people people don't even talk about
and that is cellular signal strength now
we've been going out camping I've done
hiking and what I've noticed is that
there are times where my wife who has a
series eight or my kids with the SE
Apple watches will not have cellular
connectivity the signal is not good
enough but my ultra is able to get a
signal and that is a big deal if you're
buying this thing to be able to have
access to those kind of things when you
are on the go and that would be a big
reason somebody might want to get the
ultra over a regular Apple watch now
number six is battery longevity for most
of the year I have not needed to check
the battery health of the ultra but when
I was making that iPhone video and my
Promax hit 91 in about 10 or so months I
decided to check my watch and I was
really surprised when I saw 100 battery
health but I guess I shouldn't have
batteries don't just degrade with heat
and time but also with Cycles and those
are counted based on a full discharge
and then charge so because this Ultra
lasts so long and I charge mine most
nights so it doesn't get too low and
with that I have optimized battery
charging enabled so also it doesn't stay
at a hundred percent for very long the
the battery longevity on this thing is
excellent now my previous Apple watch
got down to 80 in just over two years
which means I wasn't eligible to get
Apple Care replacement for the battery
and then at that point at 80 battery
health it no longer lasted me a full day
and the same thing with my kids first
gen SE because he's not connected to an
iPhone and it's connected with cellular
it literally dies during dinner time and
now the battery needs to get replaced
and because of that I'm thinking of
buying my kid an Apple Watch Ultra just
for the battery life I don't want to
give them an iPhone yet so I want him
just to have a watch so I can still
contact them and see where he's at but
right now it is dying so quickly that it
kind just defeats the purpose and that
will bring me into the negatives but the
last positive that surprised me is just
the overall usability especially with
the crown being blocked at first I
didn't really like this design but I
have had almost no accidental
um you know different presses that would
enable different modes I didn't want to
say out loud that are very annoying and
wrapping up all the battery life the
super bright large screen which I
absolutely love and that probably has to
be the last one just the usability is
amazing now the first negative I have to
talk about is the size now right now I'm
used to it but if Apple would have made
a smaller Apple watch there's a chance I
could have got that one and I definitely
would have bought one for my kid
probably a used one if they had a
smaller size now I know that a lot of
people would have also bought one for
example my wife she would have liked one
if they had a smaller size option so I
think apple is losing out online out of
sales for that with that the next
downside is the thickness when I first
got it I was very excited to use the
sleep tracking features now my old watch
would die too quickly and it would take
too long to charge for me to be able to
use that but with the ultra's battery
life I was finally gonna do it but
unfortunately I just couldn't get myself
to consistently wear it because of the
Comfort this thing is so much thicker
than the standard Apple watch that's
just as flat out uncomfortable to sleep
with because of that I ended up going to
the smart ring that we recently did a
video on with both Vadim and I are
wearing them if that is great for that
function but if they could just make a
little bit thinner that would be nice if
that would mean to go for lower battery
life or not have the ultra bright screen
I think I don't know if I would want to
make the trade-off because I love those
features but I definitely think that it
would be a lot more comfortable being
slightly thinner now the next one is the
action button when this thing came out I
thought that was the coolest thing
having a programmable button built into
the Apple watch but to be honest after
the first couple weeks or so I pretty
much stopped using it now I had a preset
to the exercise function but sometimes I
would just forget in the auto detect
feature works so well that it pops up
right away and I just started using that
instead now right now I have it mapped
to the flashlight but I also don't need
that very often my iPhone's flashlight
is way better than just having the
screen turn on so I pretty much never
use it so if you guys have a good use
case for the action button let me know
but I think on the upcoming iPhones
that's going to be something that's a
lot more useful now the next one is
something that I would love Apple to put
in and that is regular Qi wireless
charging being able to just place this
anywhere on a cheap pad in my car on my
desk and to be able to charge it up
would be really nice especially if
you're out and about and this is not
just with the ultra I think is in
general having something that's
dedicated for that needing a specific
stand with a specific Apple watch
charger or if I'm traveling having to
take something for it I just would just
love to be able to just place this down
and charge it and I think Apple needs to
get rid of that specific one that they
control and then the last downside is
not really with the watch but it's with
the accessories and that is the fact
that Apple still does not make a
titanium watch band when they first
released it I thought maybe they would
put something out a few months later
half a year later but they haven't I
showed off this cheap one that I have
bought but unlike the Apple watch with
its crazy durability and fingerprint
resistance this band is all scratched up
and I think it'd be great if they made
one that fit perfectly had a perfect
match had the fingerprint resistance and
that would not get scratched up so
hopefully they do that with the next
apple watch and you guys may be doing
this video here how often I get
notifications it's really really nice so
overall I would say that this is one of
Apple's best products in a very long
time I would highly recommend it
um the positives just outweigh all the
negatives by far so if you're thinking
about buying one of these I would say
right now go get a good deal on a used
one there's used ones on Facebook
Marketplace Craigslist or Ebay you can
get a refurbished one using the Amazon
links down below as well or just wait a
little bit longer for the second
generation version coming out you guys
let me know your thoughts on your Apple
watch if you guys have bought one go
ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right over there that's been Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you